نعم في محيط جامعه الاقصى في هذه اللحظات
اليات الاحتلال الى الشرق من هذه الجامعه
وتقوم بعمليه تجريف ووضع سواتر على ما
يبدو في تلك المنطقه القريبه من الجامعه
الاقصى اضافه الى ايضا الكليه الجامعيه
التي نتواجد فيها الان وقبل قليل دخلنا
الجامعه هناك جسامين اربعه شهداء داخل
الجامعه هؤلاء الشهداء تعرضوا لقصف من قبل
المدفعيه الاسرائيليه التي استهدفت احدى
خيام النازحين بالقرب من جامعه الاقصى وتم
نقلهم الى الى الجام مع نفسها حتى يتسنى
نقلهم الى
مستشفيات في مدينه رفح لان مستشفى راصر
يصعب الوصول اليه في هذه اللحظات من كافه
مناطق خان يونس بفعل حصار اليات الاحتلال
لهذه المنطقه وتواجد اليات الاحتلال ومن
يتحرك في هذه الشوارع المؤديه الى مستشفى
ناصر في هذه اللحظات يتعرض لاطلاق النار
من قبل اليات الاحتلال وكذلك من طائرات
الاحتلال المسيره التي تطلق النار بشكل
كثيف في هذه اللحظات في في الكليه الجمعيه
هي ايضا القريبه من جامعه الاقصى هنا
جثمان شهيد شهيده في ملقاه على الارض
وحولها ذووها يحاولون ايضا نقلها الى
مدينه رفح حيث هذا الشارع الغربي من قطاع
غزه المؤدي من خان يونس الى مدينه رفح حتى
هذه اللحظه هذا الشارع متاح لحركه
المواطنين وهنا حركه نزوح كبيره من قبل
المواطنين الذين لجوا الى جامعه الاقصى
والكليه الجامعيه حيث يتحركون الان بتجاه
مدينه رفح او اي مكان يعني ياويه ويحفظهم
من نيران الاحتلال القريبه جدا من جامعه
الاقصى وحركه النزوح هذه كبيره وصط معاناه
كبيره جدا وماساه واضحه حيث يقوم
المواطنون بفك خيامهم في هذه اللحظات
وينقلون امتعتهم الشخصيه عبر السيارات عبر
عربات تجرها حيوانات واحيانا هناك مشاء
ايضا من المواطنين لا يستطيعون توفير مثل
هذه المواصلات في ظل ظروف المواصلات
الصعبه وعدم امتلاكهم اي وسيله مواصلات
لنقلهم الى مناطق يعني في مدينه رفح جنوب
قطاع غزه لكن هناك بعض المواطنين ما زالوا
متواجدين داخل جامعه الاقصى برغم ظروف
القاسيه وظروف القصف المحيطه بهم هنا
كان قامت ئرات الاحتلال بغاره على عدد من
الاهداف القريبه من الجامعه هناك مستودع
للاغذيه تم قصفه من قبل طائرات الاحتلال
السن الدخان لا زالت تتصاعد من هذا الم
سودع الذي كان ايضا يحوي مساعدات ل
للوكاله وكاله الغوث وتشغيل اللاجئين
وايضا هناك ايضا السنه الخان تتصعد في
الجهه الشماليه من المكان الذي اتواجد فيه
بالتحديد بالقرب من حي الامل الذي يتواجد
فيه مستشفى الامل التابع لجمعيه الهال
الاحمر الفلسطيني وعديد الغارات التي
نفذتها طائرات الاحتلال وكذلك مدفعيه
الاحتلال واطلاق النار مستمر حتى هذه
اللحظه ونحن رصدنا جزء من هذه ال من اطلاق
النار وكذلك اطلاق قذاف المدفعيه في
المنطقه وك الان
انفجار ضخم وكبير في هذه اللحظات ناتج عن
قيام اليات الاحتلال باطلاق قذيفه مدفعيه
في محيط المكان الذي تتوغل فيه اليه
الاحتلال وهو قريب من الجامعه الاقصى الذي
نتواجد فيه ونتحدث بان رصد عمليات اطلاق
النار وكذلك اطلاق القذاف المدفعيه مستمر
حتى هذه اللحظه ولكن هنا خطوره بالغه خاصه
ان المواطنين يتحركون احيانا في الشارع
المؤ من من الغرب الى الشرق وهذه في هذه
النقطه تحديدا اسماعيل ابو عمر اسمح لي
اريد منك مزيد من التفاصيل ان هذه الحركه
للنزوح في محاوله الوصول الى رفع هل هناك
ممر امن
لهؤلاء الطريق الوحيده حاليا هي الطريق
الطريق الغربيه متاحه حاليا لكن درجه
الامان ايضا خطيره جدا في ظل تواجد اليات
الاحتلال وكذلك طائرات الاحتلال المسيره
ولكن يحاول المواطنون التحرك اتجاه رفح
برغم هذه الظروف القاسيه والصعبه والخطوره
البالغه التي تنطوي على التحرك في مثل هذه
الاجواء لكن يكون هذا الامر اكثر
يعني راحه لهم واكثر يعني امال لهم في هذه
اللحظات من التواجد داخل جامعه الاقصى في
ظل الظروف الصعبه والقصف المستمر حول
جامعه الاقصى واطلاق النار من قبل طائرات
الاحتلال ايضا جامعه الاقصى نفسها تعرضت
خاصه المدخل الجامعه تعرض لقصف مدفعي تم
تدمير جزء من هذا المدخل بعد سقوط قذيفه
مدفعيه على بوابه ومدخل جامعه الاقصى وهنا
حاله حيره من قبل المواطنين والنازحين
المتواجدين داخل الجامعه اين يتحركون اين
يذهبون في ظل هذه الظروف الصعبه ماذا عن
وتيره الاشتباكات الميدانيه ايضا اسماعيل
نعم نستمع في هذه اللحظات الى اشتباكات
واطلاق نار متبادل ما بين قوات الاحتلال
والمقاومه الفلسطينيه المقاومه الفلسطينيه
يعني في هذه اللحظات يعني اعادت تموضعها
في بعض المناطق وكانت قد استعدت لذلك عبر
التموضع في بعض النقاط للاشتباك مع قوات
الاحتلال هي تطلق قذائفها المدفعيه او
تطلق قذائفها المضاده للدروع باتجاه اليه
الاحتلال تطلق احيانا قذائف الهاون باتجاه
تحش دت لاليات الاحتلال في المناطق التي
تركزت فيها هذه الاليات خاصه في الاجزاء
الشرقيه منها من منطقه معسكر خانيونس
وكذلك منطقه حي الامل وايضا الان الاليات
تتواجد ما بين منطقه ال حاج تفاح سابقا
كما يعرف في خانيونس وكذلك المنطقه التي
يتواجد فيها تتواجد فيها جامعه الاقصى في
منطقه غرب خار يونس وهذه الاليات تقوم
باعمال مناوره في الشارع ما بين الشمال
والجنوب تتحرك باتجاه احد المواقع
العسكريه التابعه للمقاومه الفلسطينيه
وعلى ما يبدو هذا هو هدف الاحتلال الوصول
الى هذا الموقع من اجل قيام باعمال حفريات
او عمليات بحث كما فعلت سابقا في مواقع
عسكريه عديده في قطاع غزه طيب من المعلوم
اسماعيل ان الوضع الانساني متدهور في
خانيونس وهناك نقص في العديد من الامدادات
الضروريه لحياه المواطنين الان ما المخاوف
التي تطل على هؤلاء المواطنين الان بالنظر
لاستمرار القصف بهذه الكثافه وايضا
المخاوف من قطع الطريق تحديدا الرئيسي
طريق الرشيد قبل ان تجيبني اسماعيل بصور
جديده توفرت من خان يونس نشاهد
فيها تصاعد اعمده الدخان بكثافه واصوات
اطلاقات ناريه واشتباكات اذا نشاهد اكثر
من موقع قريبين من ب قريبين من بعضهما
هذين الموقعين حيث تتصاعد بتزامن هذه
الاعمده للدخان التي تشي اذا بقصف كثيف
ينفذ على هذه المنطقه تفضل
اسماعيل
الاوضاع ما سويه وصعبه جدا في ظل هذا
التصعيد الاسرائيلي والوصول الى المناطق
الغربيه لمحافظه خان يونس ما يعني ان كل
ما هو شرق المكان الذي تتواجد فيه قوات
الاحتلال ويه الاحتلال سيصر